visible à des kilomètres à la ronde
l'épaisse fumée fait craindre le pire
aux parisiens peu avant 19 heures
les images font frissonner les foules
bien vite doivent se rendre à l'évidence
lorsque les pompiers s'activent devant
notre dame de paris leur joyau est en
train d'être dévorés par les flammes
et le brasier a des allures d'enfer sur
terre le feu aurait pris naissance dans
les combles là où se trouve la charpente
et la toiture de l'édifice qui a plus de
huit siècles d'existence des centaines
de pompiers ont beau être mobilisé leurs
tuyaux d'arrosage semble dérisoire face
à la catastrophe qui ne laisse pas grand
chance à ce morceau de l'histoire de
france
impuissants les parisiens assiste bouche
bée un spectacle qui désole toute la
planète s'est vu 150 ans d'histoire
voilà ça fait mal au coeur c'est comme
ça on offre ici et puis une heure plus
tard du haut de ses 93 m la flèche de la
cathédrale s'écroule causant la stupeur
parmi la foule sur la seine à bord des
bateaux c'est la consternation chez les
touristes voir ce symbole s'écroulait
c'en est trop pour le recteur de notre
dame de paris
j'ai entendu tomber la flèche alors ça
c'est comme ça
pendant ce temps le feu redouble de
puissance et les jets d'eau peine à
atteindre les flammes minuscule face au
monstre de feu les pompiers tentent de
sauver ce qu'il reste de la toiture des
efforts en vain puisque une bonne partie
de la charpente est désormais réduite en
cendres une tristesse immense et une
épreuve
vraiment
épreuve terrible
dans les rues la ferveur chrétienne
s'activent en hommage à la grande dame
qui se consume un spectacle surréaliste
on n'arrive a pas créé c'est un symbole
très fort c'est voilà on est
complètement démunis solidarité aussi de
la part des autres églises de la ville
lumière qui font retentir leurs cloches
et alors que leur ville plonge dans
l'anus bouleversé mais reconnaissant des
parisiens applaudissent ce qu'ils ont
réussi à limiter les ravages ici
frédéric arnould radio canada montréal